ah mais non Hippolyte combien de fois
faudra-t-il te dire que l'on ne peut
jouer qu'un pion à la fois et non pas
deux c'est pour que tu perds de plus
vite quasimir j'ai tellement faim moi
c'est vrai un Casimir nous a promis un
fameux goûter et bien si poli continue à
tricher comme ça il ne leur a
certainement pas
mais je ne triche pas quasiment
j'accélère
en tous les cas moi je joue la prochaine
partie avec le gagnant et je vais
l'écraser
petit renard prétentieux prétend battre
quasimirus il doit être atteint d'une
crise de folie
le téléphone
allô
oui ce type c'est bien ici
attention je n'ai rien contre la malle
dans la main tout de suite quoi voilà
voilà qu'est-ce qu'il y a
alors
tu vas comprendre c'est moi Leonard
bonjour Julie ah non non je ne comprends
nous avons dû être coupé c'est un quel
sujet
si je peux venir garder ton kiosque mais
avec plaisir Julie oh je saurais très
bien m'en occuper à tout de suite je
passe par le tunnel ça va plus vite
à tout à l'heure
bon
tu sais Léonard je veux dire quasiment
c'est à moi qu'elle téléphonait Julie
mais non c'était à moi ah non c'est à
moi c'est un à moi c'est à moi
maintenant
à moi si je suis sûr que c'est à moi
elle téléphonait à moi je suis bien
contente que Léonard est accepté de
garder mon kiosque il faut que j'aille
au port chercher mes nouveaux colis les
jouets les bonbons les surprises je vais
tout lui expliquer
bonjour tout le monde
à personne bonjour Julie bonjour Léana
je suis pratée à tout remplacer un
nettoyé et à manger et quoi non non je
veux dire arranger c'est ma langue qui a
fourché
et bien je vais tout t'expliquer Léana
voilà pour les jouets et les bonbons
c'est facile tu te sers de ces sachets
pour les bouteilles Leonard tu m'écoutes
pour les bouteilles de limonade c'est
plus compliqué elles sont consignées
[Musique]
une bouteille quand il est intéressant
de la récupérer alors il demande un peu
d'argent en plus et il le donne quand la
personne lui rapporte la bouteille moi
quand un enfant me rapporte une
bouteille de limonade je lui donne un
bonbon
tiens d'ailleurs je vais te faire la
démonstration merci Arnaud
et je te la rapporte et tu me donnes un
bonbon on va essayer alors je suis en
france et je t'ai rapporté cette
bouteille tiens Julie voilà une
bouteille
quelle Léana voilà un bonbon
enfin je vois que tu as très bien
compris Léonard
merci à me demander non non non très
bien je donne un bonbon je mange un
bonbon
on me rapporte la bouteille je mange un
il est vraiment adorable ce renard
[Musique]
tout seul
salut Léonard salut Casimir alors ton
nouveau travail te convient-il
parfaitement Casimir quel bon ventamen
et bien j'ai entendu dire quand tu
reprenais les vieilles bouteilles
consignées
une bouteille un bonbon une bouteille un
bon bon alors allons-y tout de suite
alors voici une bouteille un bonbon un
bonbon deux bouteilles deux bouteilles
[Musique]
5 bouteilles 5 bonbons
6 bouteilles
si bonbon
enfin j'ai entendu dire que
je ne vais tout de même pas distribuer
tous mes bonbons contre toutes les
vieilles bouteilles de l'île seul les
bouteilles de limonade sont consignées
ils ne font pas confondre vieille
bouteille un bouteille ancienne
exactement à mon avis il y en a même
certaines qui mériteraient de bonbons de
ton avis vous allez partir tous les deux
Casimir tu vas m'en porter tout ça et je
vais donner mon kiosque à garder à
hydraulique alors là du coup tu cours
en tout cas moi qu'avec vous deux il
faut lisse
alors là
je vais t'expliquer comment fonctionne
la consigne des bouteilles de limonade
ah bon je préfère me retirer avant que
ce casimirus ne me marche sur les pattes
moi aussi ouais
rendez-vous à la Maison d'accord et
merci
quand un enfant te rapporte sa bouteille
de limonade vide un bonbon
je suis épuisée heureusement que c'est
terminé il faut que je libère ce pauvre
Hippolyte qui s'est donné tant de mal
salut Pauline me voilà alors tout s'est
bien passé très très bien Julie oh mais
dis-moi tu tu as vendu beaucoup de
bonbons mais beaucoup sont presque vides
pas mal je suis ravi de t'avoir fait
plaisir et je t'ai même réservé une
surprise c'est vrai voyons ça j'ai
employé une méthode de formidable
imaginez je dois le dire par mon ami
Léonard et mon cousin Casimir tu crois
qu'elle est si formidable que ça bien
sûr Julie bien sûr puisqu'elle est
scientifiques
les bouteilles de limonade sont en
quelque sorte l'emballage de la limonade
les les échangés contre un bonbon te
permet de récupérer ses emballages
précieux et ainsi de les réutiliser
exactement bien j'ai donc appliqué ce
cette méthode aux autres emballages
je ne comprends pas comment ça tu vas
voir tu vas voir quasimi Casimir
viens vite
mais non il est parti se coucher allez
viens c'est juste pour montrer à Julie
d'accord
bien voilà voilà la méthode un bonbon un
papier
un bonbon
un papier un bonbon un bonbon
un autre papier un autre bonbon
un autre papier
un autre bonbon et ainsi de suite
[Musique]